[Applause]
[Music]
America fractured febrile furious old
wounds that have never healed pulled
apart in the middle of a pandemic a
country confronts the virus but can't
seem to overcome racial division on the
streets of Minneapolis where George
Floyd's death lit this tinderbox the
protesters persisted undeterred by a
curfew with the police strikingly hard
to find Minnesota's governor believes
the carnage is the work of extremist
outsiders so as you saw this expand
across the United States and you start
to see whether it be domestic terrorism
whether it be ideological extremists to
fan the group or whether it be
international destabilization of of how
our country works those elements are
present in all of this but in a society
rich with inequity there is anger at
institutions everywhere from Los Angeles
to Colorado and Kentucky
[Applause]
in Atlanta it was the CNN headquarters
targeted at the core of this although
unresolved rage at the disproportionate
number of African Americans killed by
police mad as hell I woke up wanting to
see the world burn down yesterday but
tired of seeing black man die he
casually put his knee on a human beings
neck for nine minutes as he died like a
zebra and a clutch of a lion's jaws the
White House was also engulfed by
frustration the president warning
vicious dogs and ominous weapons would
have been deployed the people breached
the fence in Florida he spent the day
basking in the glory of the successful
SpaceX Murch emerged to the sound of
Matt Jonah
after earlier pushing for a clampdown
they've got to get tougher they've got
to get tougher they've got to be strong
honor the memory of George Floyd honor
his memory they have to get tougher and
by being tougher they will be honoring
his memory but they cannot let that
happen
with the man occupying 1600 Pennsylvania
Avenue is in the minds of some a big
part of the problem as the president
tried to find something to celebrate
back here in Washington there is no
welcoming party just a lot of discontent
and division there at Chavan the officer
who put his knee on George Floyd's neck
has now been charged with third-degree
murder but it's not enough for many this
is a nation in crisis rattled by
dysfunction smoldering with a leader
currently unable or unwilling to soothe
or detail Sky News Washington
[Music]